hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
raise your hand if when you were young
you wondered if it wouldn't be better if
there was some instruction manual for
being a human being no matter what
context you live in no matter how you're
brought up there's all sorts of unspoken
rules and regulations out there things
you're supposed to know that no one ever
actually tells you explicitly right so
today's guest camilla pang has set out
to do this to write the instruction
manual for being a human being and she
does it from a very unique perspective
camilla was diagnosed with autism
spectrum disorder as well as adhd
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
so when she was a kid for a long time
she struggled to understand what was
going on with her family her friends
what were the things that other people
sensed and knew
implicitly that she wasn't privy to
right and she had to work it out
explicitly figure out ways to understand
what was the subtext of what her friends
were saying why people were laughing in
certain places how to have normal
conversations now she's been very very
successful at this uh you know these
conditions are ones that have varying
degrees of severity camilla has done
very very well for herself she has a phd
in biochemistry she has a book that
she's written that is going to be the
basis of our conversation today that
recently won the royal society prize for
science books of the year so but
nevertheless there are there's a real
difference in perspective uh there's
some things that some of us take for
granted that other human beings other of
our fellow people have to learn
explicitly so the great thing about
camilla's book is that not only does she
go into
how people behave from sort of an
outsider's point of view almost like the
classic anthropologist from mars kind of
thought experiment why are these weirdos
acting in these different ways but she
uses science metaphors to explain why
people act in different ways so as a
scientist camilla always thinks in terms
of science i think a lot of science
friends out there are going to know
what this is like they're going to be
sympathetic here that you learn
something that is crystal clear within
the world of science so you know how
bayes's theorem works or how general
relativity works and that serves as a
metaphor as an analogy for the
complicated and difficult to understand
question of how human beings behave and
why they do that so the great thing
about camilla's book is that it's both
interesting as sort of psychology as
understanding how human beings really do
behave but she sneaks in there a lot of
science communication a lot of pedagogy
about different realms of science
whether it's psychology or biochemistry
or computer science or so forth uh and
it's always of course just interesting
to hear about human beings from slightly
different perspectives one of the
issues that we have as a species is that
we are the only species who writes books
and does science right so there's sort
of not a lot of data that we can get
from an unbiased external observer and
listening to different kinds of human
beings with different experiences and
different perspectives is the best that
we can do to understand ourselves just a
little bit better a little bit more
fully so with that let's go
[Music]
camilla pang welcome to the mindscape
podcast
like having me on here i'm fascinated by
the book you wrote uh because thinking
of it as an instruction manual for being
a human being so i mean you have uh kind
of an excuse for wanting such a an
instruction manual and writing it but i
think that we all need it or have
wondered about this uh at some point in
our life so i mean maybe tell us a
little bit about your motivation for why
you thought this was an important book
to write well when i was um writing it
when i was little i didn't actually
realize i was writing a book i just
wrote it i ended up writing a lot of
notes that
helped me understand what was going on
around me because i'm autistic and i've
also got adhd and so that kind of makes
a very interesting existence where you
constantly feel out of phase with pretty
much every person that you meet and so i
wanted to make sense and feel like i
belonged and so for that i seeked out
science which is kind of concrete
language that i'd hook my days to and in
the end when i realized that that manual
was actually useful to someone else i
was like oh
oh that gave me the motivation funnily
enough to actually make it into a book
otherwise it was just a guilty pleasure
of journaling lots so you were actually
literally writing things down for years
that that eventually appeared in the
book yeah completely and it was inspired
by the books that i've just you know
read through science through articles
from my phd i actually ended up writing
a little bit of my book within my phd
thesis and my my supervisor was like
what's this it's nice but it's not
actually academic writing and i'm like
oh no
which is really embarrassing so i knew i
had to put it somewhere and so i
couldn't chuck it away because it was a
part of me that i'd built and i invested
a lot of time and emotion in and so i
was like i need to put it somewhere and
so that's when i realized it was
actually separate from science and it
was more of my own experiment but but
it's great because what you do in the
book uh i mean on the one hand you're
doing something where uh you're helping
people understand what it is to be human
like the sort of classic example of an
anthropologist from mars or from a
different alien race comes down and
observes us and tries to figure out what
we're doing but sneakily you're teaching
people a lot of science along the way
right
there's actually a lot of introduction
to a lot of very interesting parts of
science squeezed into one book in this
framing device yeah exactly and that's
one of the reasons why i felt like it
was quite nice because then even if a
lot of the audience of the book
understood the concepts that i found
difficult at least they would feel like
for me it was an effort to make um
humans
uh or people human to me through science
and because science is one of those
subjects that can raise eyebrows when
you say i'm a scientist there's a table
can be quite alienated and i wanted to
humanize it so that people um
actually relate to it on a level that i
relied on for my everyday so complete
the loop it's great it reminded me a
little bit of uh francis ford coppola's
quote about the godfather the movie when
he made it he wasn't sure whether anyone
would like the movie but he said anyone
who watched it would at least get a good
recipe for pasta sauce so
you can have more than one goal when you
when you do something like this
so so
this is a an extremely sort of
unfair ambitious question but um so
you're someone who uh is autistic or on
the autism uh spectrum how should i
exactly say that and then
for the people who are not as familiar
with this whole idea as they could be
how should we think about what that
means
um
that's a very good question i think um
there's a lot of language that limits
how people view neurodiversity so i
think by questioning how someone wants
to be viewed as a very good start so
actually yeah i'm autistic and i've also
got adhd and the thing is with autism
it's one of those kind of um
it's one of those um neurodiverse
conditions
that affects social connection you don't
often get the nuances or it's trying to
contextualize things and construct them
for example abstract concepts such as
tidying your room in my case or
understanding someone's intention you
assume that everyone is kind of a
neutral agent but actually there's a lot
of unhidden a lot of hidden rules that
people are sensitive to but they don't
speak
and
when it comes to autism you also have no
feel of the senses you have a often a
sensory pro disorder and so what that
means is that you get overwhelmed by
lots of things that just manage to
filter out on the day-to-day basis and
so you get afraid of things that people
find silly but actually to us it's
something that's triggering
um i would also like to just mention how
and you know the how autism manifests in
women and marginalized graphics for
example black and ethnic minority is
extremely different to how it's
benchmarked in white male um
in white males so this is another thing
itself is in the presenter cell there's
a lot of societal pressures and it's
quite complicated okay yeah i mean we're
still but representation yeah that's a
good point that i hadn't i hadn't really
thought of because i mean maybe i can
ask a little bit more about
um the connection between these
different aspects that you just raised
because you know on the one hand there's
the social aspect
of trying to understand
what is going on in the minds of other
people uh if your if your intuitions or
expectations are naturally a little bit
different and then there's the story
about being very sensitive to uh sounds
and light and noise and crowds are these
connected in some way do you think i
mean why do they go hand in hand so
often well i mean i mean that's just uh
an interesting question because
there are some people with autism that
don't have um sensory personal
actually very tolerant and
they don't you know you can it's you can
have someone with autism who's just
primarily focused on the sensory aspects
of things or often it's called
hypersensitivity or sensory processes so
much like the the symptoms of
neurodiversity themselves be it through
calculus or dyspraxia dyslexia autism
adhd you do have symptoms which are
overlapping the same could be applied
for the name of autism itself so uh that
makes a lot of sense it's it's a bit
different
it does seem like we're in the process
of just beginning to understand this i
mean i'm certainly not an expert but my
impression is that the way that
uh the medical psychological community
thinks about autism is changing over
time as it gets more input from people
who are actually autistic for example
yeah no completely and this is one of
the things i want to challenge is
there's a lot of research that has been
great for developing methods to help
people who are who manifest
traditionally as autistic
but now we are raising the um uh barrier
of what autism looks like by
um by raising the voices of those who
who have it but don't present in this
traditional way so
i think um the more people that we
empower which is what i want my book to
do i want people to be like wait a
minute i'm autistic i'm autistic but i
have a voice and i can talk about my
experience and not be ashamed of it
because the more we know about the
nature of autism itself the more we're
likely to actually capture that in its
diagnosis right absolutely so great so
with that uh as the background let's get
into uh your book because i thought it
was really interesting i mean it wasn't
just here's a little bit of science i
learned about the brain or about autism
or anything like that or even just a
bunch of uh techniques that you learn to
deal with the world it was sort of using
science as an analogy or inspiration for
developing these techniques is that is
that a safe way to put it you think i
guess so i think when you're you know
you let you know when you're a kid
you'll try and find the language which
makes sense to you translate the world
into
the
movements of what you're learning and um
i found it quite difficult and um quite
a bit too abstract to associate myself
with any characters tv
or
um those made through the media or
stories and so i was like i don't really
have
that but i know that when i read about
science it affects me
and i and i think
one of the main things in making your
own language when you feel completely
out of sync is knowing what affects you
and not being ashamed of it but the fact
that the movement of leaves and me kind
of going to leaves and questioning their
movement and why each movement was
irreversible because of entropy was a
lot more effective than looking at a
disease and so i think this is where i
found my language in advertising yeah no
that makes perfect sense it also is
going to delay me a second because now i
want to ask about the question of
representation uh of of people with
different neurodivergent behaviors or
thoughts in tvs and movies because i'd
forgotten but there's this great example
of drax the destroyer in the guardians
of the galaxy did you ever see the
guardians of the galaxy i haven't but um
so there is a character um who is i mean
he's an alien so he is he's not actually
labeled as autistic or asperger's or
anything like that but many of his
behaviors are similar and one of them uh
was you know he takes things very very
literally and there are people who you
know who've said autistic people who
have said you know that they recognized
themselves in him and it it made me
think of this incredibly uh charming
little story you tell in the book where
someone calls your house and you pick up
the phone and they say uh i'm calling to
see if your mom is there
and you say yes she is and then you hang
up the phone
and so is that i mean
so is that kind of uh taking things
literally rather than figuratively is
that one of the one of the ways in which
uh
things that you need to train yourself
to pick up on what other people mean in
subtext below the surface yes oh yes big
time not just subtext but in the context
of when you meet them and how they talk
there's lots of unhidden messages that
fall out of
this interaction between how they talk
context and this is the thing that i'm
constantly trying to tune my attention
to to make sure i understand what's
going on that people
that people feel naturally so
a lot of it is trying to interpret
subtext and also naturally i think you
can call it a form of naivety but i
don't really assume that anyone has
gender because i don't have an agenda so
i'm like hey
i just take you as you are and so i
think there are many people that don't
really uh find that fun that weird but
i'm like how can you be anything else so
yeah it's also a thing you see people
and i think as you mentioned in a couple
places in the book
maybe it's especially difficult because
of the particular culture that you are
embedded in namely uh the british one
where being reticent and understating
your feelings is just commonplace
whereas maybe if you grew up in italy
where proclaiming your feelings loudly
would might have made things a little
bit easier
oh yeah yeah no
it's an interesting one that you you
mentioned because
in the uk i've had to work extra extra
hard
to
really tune into
the non-verbal
um in between body language signals that
can make a conversation right and so i
think it's actually helped me a lot more
because how it's had to force me to
detect those nuances which probably
otherwise would have been masked by
actually being transparent another kind
all right you've you've playing the game
on hard mode i think that makes that
makes perfect sense so good so let's oh
yeah
no no no choices yeah so let's get into
the the the details of these wonderful
examples that you use i think we
probably won't be able to get to all of
them but i picked out some of my
favorites so you open the book
talking about decision making and
machine learning and you know we all
make decisions and that's a tricky thing
but you draw this wonderful analogy
uh with supervised versus unsupervised
learning boxes versus trees so tell the
audience like
why has it been helpful
uh to be inspired by concepts from
machine learning when you're trying to
make decisions in your in your everyday
life yes so basically when i was um
probably um i'm like 10 years old when i
was trying to make sense of things in
humans naturally want to pigeonhole
everything and this i took the elite
extreme to the point where i got
fooled of it being a continuum right and
so it makes a difference between having
lots of different op it makes a
difference to being like i'm either this
this this this versus knowing what the
options are in the context of what
you're actually doing
so i was like i don't feel like these
boxes that i'm putting myself in are
joining up and i feel a lot of anxiety
about it and so i had to find another
way to kind of navigate through events
that aren't predictable or deterministic
because that's just life and so i
thought well i need a different approach
and to not be so classified in it and
this is when
when i looked about unsupervised
learning where you start from the data
and from that you have to cluster
depending on what you have to then make
a decision that naturally converges to a
certain whereas if you have a preset
kind of conditional already there pretty
difficult to kind of engineer that on
the spot when things go wrong so this is
what led me to looking between box-like
things
donating money to help people can be a
wonderful and selfless act but how can
you feel confident that your donations
are improving or saving lives
effectively you could do weeks of
research to find the charities that are
out there what programs they run how
effective those programs are and how the
charity might use your money or you
could visit givewell.org there you'll
get a short vetted list of the best
charities they found at saving or
improving lives per dollar over 50 000
donors have used givewell to donate more
than 750 million dollars rigorous
evidence suggests that these donations
will save tens of thousands of lives and
improve the lives of millions more and
the best part is give well is free
givewell wants to empower as many donors
as possible to make informed decisions
about their donations they publish all
of their research on the site for free
no sign up required so go to
givewell.org to read more about their
research or donate to any of their
recommended charities again that's
givewell.org and enter sean carroll's
mindscape at checkout so they know we
sent you
yeah so i'm actually not an expert
certainly no one thinks i'm an expert in
machine learning so i mean maybe
we can just talk about that for its own
sake just for a second so it sounds like
there's a version of machine learning
where you start with some categories the
picture is either a cat or a dog and you
train your algorithm to distinguish cats
and dogs but then there's another
version where you say there's a bunch of
pictures and you know just try to
classify them is that is that the
distinction that you're drawing here
yeah exactly yeah so you have you know
you've got you've got classification
where you have preset can you just
preset labels for each um image or each
kind of like an event that you're
thinking of doing and you have um and
then that's the plan you've got
unsupervised learning with looking at
the data and to see what pencil boxes in
latch and it naturally falls in so you
might even have a squirrel in there you
know it depends on what
what the data shows as opposed to you
trying to fit but as you say um i think
in the book that uh the ocd aspect of
things obsessive
compulsive uh is happy with the boxes
right like if you're told ahead of time
here are the boxes here are the
categories into which the world falls
that's something you can easily uh
sympathize with but it's not good all
the time because sometimes the world
surprises you
exactly which is one of the reasons why
it's not like one or the other i wanted
to highlight both i think there's a bit
of a fallacy where people try and think
oh to be um to thinking box thinking i
can't think of tree thinking because i
won't be a proper box thinking person or
vice versa like everyone likes to be
quite essentialist in how they do things
because then it makes them feel like
they're doing it properly but most of
the time you just need to just mix it up
on the
go and that's how you do it properly
it's a great point i mean it's similar
to something that uh teen wen said a
philosopher that i had on the podcast
lee that uh he's a philosopher who
thinks about games and also how they
relate to the rest of human culture and
he says that there's a danger in
gamification because there's such a
pleasure in having clear goals and rule
and so much of a pleasure in that that
we
perceive them when they're not there and
you know this clarity of values and
goals uh can can make it hard to
understand subtleties and nuances yeah
much like when you read the works of
fiction games and gamification can
provide that essential closure that
reality and science can
not give us i mean humans crave that
sense of closure so that we can know how
to act and how to and to reaffirm that
what we've already thought is good so i
think this
whole kind of search for meaning is very
much the portable studies from 1994 1944
and the humans kind of tendency to seek
meaning and narrative actually i mean
that's a great point which i hadn't
thought of the the the connection
between the gamification in terms of
rules and
rewards is is compelling because we like
that sort of clarity but what you're
saying that
we like fiction we like stories because
there's sort of a narrative arc and
there's a payoff and there's a
conclusion and
life isn't always like that and we
should maybe resist the temptation to
make life too much like a
compact three-act hollywood structure
yes i completely agree and i could talk
about this for quite a while it's a
subject that i'm very much interested in
and i think potentially um i mean don't
quote me on this but this is something
that's kind of stirring in my head
when people um
i asked my dad about this actually
because he's like i know he's like 56 57
and he didn't grow up with the internet
and was i did and so i feel like a lot
of people these days feel like with so
much information
you know we have everything we need
therefore with the answer it's almost
like seeking answers through this
space of information versus living them
out through and i think that can be
quite toxic and so that whole craving to
foreclosure is potentially increased or
or the expectation for closure is higher
because we have more data but that
doesn't mean it's good date
well that's the thing like when you get
a lot of data in some of it will be
misleading which which brings up the
next point i wanted to mention because
you mentioned in this chapter that one
of the lessons from thinking about
machine learning was to embrace the
possibility of error that your
conclusions are not always going to be
true and to be willing to update them
yeah completely i think that's in my um
which was that chapter nine nine how to
learn from your mistakes was that the oh
boy i'm not gonna remember but but i did
you do you have a wonderful chapter that
i want to get to next on baze's theorem
and empathy maybe that's the one uh
where we we should go to because you
know uh well
give me your version of bayesian
reasoning because i love it and i've
talked about in the podcast many times
but i will never i will never tire of
explaining it
well the more i read about it the more i
realized that if i
humor myself into going completely based
not even thinking about anything else i
will quickly end up doing exactly what i
would have done 10 years ago i think
it's it's a very interesting model to
use especially when you contextualize
whether something will happen or not if
you have no sense of context or if you
want to kind of predict what will happen
however it assumes that determinism is
based on just what's happened before but
it's not just about that and so and so
which is one of the reasons why i
absolutely loved um you know constructed
theory because it enables you to see the
outward projection of what could based
on what can and can't you know
physically in the laws of physics
compared to what's already happened so
the more i read about it the more i
realized how useful it is in looking at
events that precede um certain others
but it's quite limiting and i think the
more we try and model the chaos
and for intelligent systems the more we
realize that we might hit a wall quite
quickly okay yeah i completely uh i see
that the the point you're making um i
mean one of the
one of the features of bayesian
reasoning which is both a pro and a con
is that you have some explicit priors
right
uh it's both a pro because you you're
not
starting from scratch every time you
look at a new phenomenon it's a con
because you can miss important things if
your priors are too strongly uh pushed
against them i mean has
have you
so what how has it changed your way of
dealing with other human beings to think
of to think in bayesian terms to think
like well if they're acting in a certain
way
it's most likely it's for this reason is
that is that a
useful explicit thought process for you
yeah i think so but then
if you do that to such an extent so i've
done it to the point of almost um i
wouldn't say insanity but i do it to
such an extent where i try and push its
limitations and question is this
actually how it is because you can only
some you can only know so much about a
person their intentions generally
but you just need to be open-minded that
you know your heat map protection of
what of their reasoning is only part of
it
and i think knowing that they could be
doing something that you can't predict
is actually quite a normal thing and you
shouldn't take it personally right okay
people like to justify
people like to justify other people's um
actions according to what they think
they are but actually it's not much well
it's always a tricky thing i mean i i
had paul bloom on the podcast and he's a
psychologist who's written a book
against empathy he thinks that empathy
is overrated
and his argument is that we tend to
empathize
yeah so sorry i don't know are you
what is your predilection there do you
think that empathy is overrated or
underrated it depends on what context um
i think that there's an
underrepresenting of empathy in order
because we don't like to hug as often
but that doesn't mean you know i've got
my own opinions
sure yeah i think you know but
empathy in the sense of
uh trying to model or understand other
people's inner states to put yourselves
in the shoes of somebody else
is that something that is very useful to
you
yes that's why i wrote the book
the book is a gesture of empathy oh very
good yeah that's
a good way of putting it right
yeah but but paul's argument is that uh
because we're better at empathizing with
people like ourselves than with people
who are very different we can trick
ourselves into thinking we're we're
being good human beings whereas we're
actually just prioritizing people who
are like us we should guard he he wants
to put rationality
in opposition to empathy inside yes
actually that's a good point i think
yeah i know that's his name that's
really cool i think he makes a good
point there's an affinity bias in
empathy
because you have this you know if you
have something in common with someone
you're more likely to feel like you can
predict what they want and therefore
connect with them but you know that's
exactly right quickly an echo chamber so
it's paul bloom b-l-o-o-m like bloom on
the rose uh you should check it out the
the podcast episode and his book but um
uh the final thing on baze's theorem is
uh you mentioned that it's a useful way
of thinking about self-regulation that
you know you have we all have instincts
right we all have
reactions to things that we experience
in the world that maybe are not
completely cognitive that are sort of
pre-cognitive or whatever and uh so for
instance you mentioned that you react
strongly to certain smells and you've
been able to use bayesian reasoning to
say that smell probably won't kill me
it's not killed anybody else yet as it
hasn't killed me yet and is that kind of
updating uh really effective for you it
is actually yeah no definitely it helps
rationalize triggers that um
are there there's um
the thing is with autism is
especially with um
what's it called um
high functioning autism or autism that
isn't presented as dramatically to other
people that isn't because we feel it any
less it's like we created mechanisms so
that we can feel our triggers and try
and internalize them and process them so
that we look normal so i know that the
smell of smoke won't immediately kill
but i know
that it triggers me my i find it very
stressful but
it occurs everywhere okay
and i think about you know the base
level rate of inhaling a tiny bit of you
know pollution and you know am i gonna
die there and then well if so then it
would be in the news um so i try and i
try and kind of talk myself through the
kind of incidents of you know what's
happened before what's the likelihood so
i i use base things rationalize whether
to be worried or not and it can help
reassure me when i'm triggered i wonder
if this is helpful to people who are not
uh autistic in uh
empathizing with people who are if you
want to put it that way because it does
sound like you have to work so much
harder uh to sort of regulate yourself
in a much more explicit and cognitive
way it just sounds exhausting to me you
know
is that is that an accurate uh
implication yes very much so it's um
it's it's definitely um takes up a lot
of energy to just exist but also to
justify yourself and to regulate
yourself and then to interact normally
with others it's it's a lot of work um
which is one of the reasons why it's
very good to acknowledge that whenever i
um i'm social i'm like yay i look normal
the days after like two days after i ah
well you know
you know and that's the thing you have
to
but you
i mean
i i admire what you've been able to do
you mentioned in the bay's chapter that
you went clubbing not because you were
really excited to go clubbing but
because this was an experiment you
needed to do to collect some data
was that was that a fruitful experiment
do you think you learned about human
beings a little bit that way
[Laughter]
i mean i don't do it
the thing is with me
that's so funny the thing is of me
though is that i'm got a bit of a
curiosity obsession like the thing
that's driven me through my anxiety and
to experiment is because i'm deeply
curious about everything and i get
really bad and fomo i get the fear of
missing out there are people doing
things that are clearly happening that i
feel like i want to be i want to be part
of even though i'm going to hate it but
it's going to help me have more of a
rounded view of the context of the
social situation
yeah and i i i'm curious and i'm a
scientist that exactly who goes against
her autism to try and figure out what's
well that's why i said it's admirable
because i do not share this impulse i
mean i think of myself as a curious
scientist but uh i love going to las
vegas and uh you know eating in the
restaurants and playing poker and i walk
by
these huge lines of people waiting to
get into the club
and i'm like no i have no interest
whatsoever in joining them in that
particular experience so
so good for you is there anything
is there any
specific example of something you
learned from that experience that that
was surprising to you um
i just it was a very specific context
that people talked about a lot in
university and so
i didn't really go in with a motive to
find anything i went in with the
curiosity thinking this isn't this is a
very different environment i wonder
how people talk more people talk less
and if they talk less then how can
people say oh i had a great night and
i'm like like so just i just loved even
on the basic fundamental level i just
found it interesting how different
people interact in contexts and i
thought
i was really curious that was enough for
me
i think that's probably a whole sequel
book about the whole clubbing experience
uh waiting to be written there
because i i don't know like i said i
don't do it so people don't talk very
much because the noise is is too loud
right is that is that a fair uh
implication
yeah
okay that's what i thought
it would drive me crazy anyway all right
uh let's move on to another chapter in
your book that i really really enjoyed
which is on memory and learning uh
obviously something that's very very
important and uh you you take an analogy
with deep learning with it with a form
of artificial intelligence uh because as
you mentioned with adhd you can easily
forget
things that you're supposed to be doing
like you come home and you know you're
wearing your jacket for the next you
know 10 minutes or a half an hour or
whatever because you just forgot to take
your jacket off so
five hours so uh i mean how how does how
has it helped you to think about deep
learning and artificial intelligence
when when you think about how to
get your memory working as it should be
that's a good question and um i think
you know i think when one has adhd um
your executive memory is is quite um
it's a bit like those mario games that
you see where he's jumping from platform
to platform and sometimes it comes
together in one line and most of the
time it's just a way and they're
circling around each other and you're
trying to catch yourself in the middle
so that you can focus on something um
and for me when it came to making
mistakes you make mistakes
on such
a frequent level you are constantly
having to self-reflect so you can focus
and i think what it's actually
highlighted is the fact because i have
this increased iteration of you know
doing something and forgetting and
having to reassess
i realized that actually you take it all
personally then you won't really get
anywhere but if you have to have to
learn from it and have that proactive
approach and kind of help you with
bigger things that you know i might have
you know the difference between
forgetting five cups of tea in the day
because you've forgotten whether you've
lost them around the house which happens
frequently versus you not applying to
this thing like it helps you
it helps you deal with these smaller and
therefore bigger things of regret right
and you assess yourself on what you act
what's actually important and how you
can act well it is very interesting
because there's this idea of you know
short-term working memory i think that
you know everyone has had the experience
of walking from one room to another
getting into the new room and say why
did i come here what was the reason why
i had to do this but but
but maybe the adhd sort of brings it
into sharper focus so it makes us
reflect on that a little bit more so
uh
if you were just if we were forgetting
about human beings and just you were
teaching me about artificial
intelligence how does a deep learning
network deal with memory like that is
there any specific i mean tell us what
deep learning is maybe that would be an
important first step there okay okay
cool so deep learning is i guess when it
comes to um
trying to model a perceptron for example
you know data in
processing unit data out you know for
example it could be like a simple
equation it's a perceptron it takes some
data and outputs something based on a
decision that you wanted to make whereas
neural networks and deep learning are a
bit more intricate in the sense that you
can have many different stimuli and many
different kind of modules can process
things independent and therefore to one
another and that they can kind of mix up
so it's a lot more complex in that
regard it's a lot more common um but
this is great because it helps kind of
um what's it called split the hairs
between points and their association to
come up with conclusions that otherwise
wouldn't really be present in the binary
um
machine learning algorithm and when it
comes to memory um neural networks can
learn from itself so the output
um of one epoch could be the input for
the next and this whole reflexive
process in itself is the ability um i
guess to have some sense of of memory i
think i use it as an analogy purely
based on the feedback loop but
memory storage is one thing but
memory and take into account in a
specific context is another which i
think we're trying to do
it makes sense and i like the the uh
comparison you did between the sort of
feedback in a deep learning algorithm uh
and self-reflection as human beings i
mean there it is right like we not only
do things and act in certain ways we
remember what we did and we say did i
act in the right way and that could
affect our behavior going forward and so
uh
i mean how how explicit do you want to
say that's a useful uh analogy there
it's quite useful when you have defined
right and wrong but most of the time
actually we don't know what's right and
wrong and we're literally gathering data
you know we're in an unclustered space
unsupervised space so you're kind of
iterating and then you're kind of trying
to find the tag whether it's the right
thing to do or the wrong thing to do i
think that's probably one of the hardest
bits is that with the computer you can't
you know we've defined right and wrong
for them but with us is actually a lot
more nuanced and complicated because not
only are we having this feedback loop
we're also trying to define what is
right and wrong based on the emerging
data and that's so um
yeah it's an analogy i use no yeah i
mean i like it because then i mean that
that reminds us that there's sort of
more than one
system going on in our brains we're
trying to interpret the world in terms
of the behavior of things and what's
going to happen next but then there's a
whole separate but related
set of judgments that we have like what
was right what was wrong you know uh and
there there's an interplay there which
which uh
like i don't know i don't know what to
say about it except it's really
complicated and really hard so thinking
about it in a more self-reflected way is
probably very useful it's very
complicated and it's not something that
is quantifiable as such because it
relies on a moral interpretation right
of what right and wrong can be which is
not something that can be formulated
and then another thing that you
mentioned that is that is crucially
important to again all of human life i
say because it is you you've written an
instruction manual for for human beings
generally um
memory is good it's good to remember
things but sometimes there are bad
memories that we can kind of get stuck
on right and kind of obsess about uh and
learning to debug our memory logs can be
a useful skill yeah completely i think
much like in science even bad data is
good data um because not bad or bad
result is a good result because it helps
you be like okay well i did that and
that happened so
it helps us kind of question our own
narrative and our minds of how we
perceive what has gone on and how we can
react that i think to debug is to be
able to do this self-reflective process
and be like okay well actually because
most of the time we're existing not not
question it and i think when we're
affected by some things you know
actually indifferent and regulated and
moderated you can perform but a lot
we're just practicing we're learning
we're learning on the job no matter how
many so
yeah i think when it comes to debugging
you need to have an element of
humility to do that well you tell
another story i mean your stories are
great you know because you you really
illuminate these these uh ideas with
specifics from your own life and there
wasn't that much detail in the story so
i was gonna ask you more about it this
was the story of the blue eyeliner where
you said that you uh decided just for
fun to wear blue eyeliner to a lunch and
the people at the lunch were not
impressed so like what what's up with
those people why were they why were they
so judgy about your blue eyeliner what
is your current thought about that
yeah well it was a tuesday so there's no
kind of occasion of why i should have
liner i was just bored one day and i
thought you know what why not yeah and
it was completely a fluke but then i
went into lunch and i scared a lot of my
friends um
and they didn't look at me the same for
the next couple of days and i thought
what
judgmental
you know i i i'm one of those people
that didn't kind of keep themselves to
themselves and so i thought you know
what when i express myself be it through
blue eyeliner i expect the same courtesy
in return but i think it was interesting
because that was different it was
another boarding school and everyone was
that was encouraged to warm and so i
think it stood out a lot more fine it
was just some it was a fun experiment
for me but
you know this is a thing take it quite
seriously so this is
so how old would you have been when this
happened i was like deemed yeah okay
it's a very judgy age right we would we
would like to hope that people who are
25 would have dealt with it better maybe
than 15 year olds just are right on the
cusp of figuring out what is appropriate
and allowed and and bad and so forth and
so you
you stepped outside the lines and they
came down on you big time
wild
well it makes me think that there's
lessons here once again there's lessons
uh not just to help autistic people
navigate the complexity of human
interaction but to help
everyone uh be a little bit more
empathetic like i mean that story really
i reacted very strongly to that story i
know it's a silly like two-line story
but i really was angry at these people
who judged you badly uh you know why
can't we learn to just let people wear
whatever makeup they want and you know
if we like it that's great if we don't
like it that that's not so great but
it's just a reminder of how incredibly
judgmental people are about other
people's personal choices that are
utterly harmless to them exactly yeah
exactly which is something that i've
noticed i've gotten older and that's one
reason why i actually quite like
london's like you could dress up how you
want and whenever you want and people
pretty much will be very accepting of
that and i really like that
multicultural um feeling you have um to
be ah and to be taken as so i think it's
gotten a lot better obviously you know
you know in a boarding school and
everyone's and every tiny little
fluctuation means a big thing you get to
choose your battles later on so you can
feel that they can express themselves
without having to feel that they also
have to because you know that's the
thing it's having more empathy and more
humility is in the everyday being more
accepting well i was going to ask that i
mean i think again everybody has this
process through their lives of finding
their people and finding their place and
so forth how important has that been for
you to just
uh you know grow up go through the high
school experience where you don't get to
choose much of your environment
to be more of a grown-up and finding
people who are more comfortable
i think the i think initially the
structure and limitations one has when
they're in boarding school um can be
quite limiting but for me
um because i crave structure that age
for direction to anchor me i think it
really benefited me because it anchored
me in a place where i could then in turn
choose what was something i liked and
didn't like i had to choose my
preferences that i needed for the next
stage of life and so i think a little
bit of structure goes a long way
um and for me it was routine it was
consistency but then when i felt like i
was stable in myself and i had i could
make that for myself you start to
venture out and that's when you need to
that's when you know to take leaps and
feel like you've got your own back so
structure is quite good for letting you
trust your own judgment and make
mistakes but also
most of the living happens when things
don't go well that's certainly true yeah
no i mean i think it's a very very good
point that that is i'm glad you said it
out loud that the structure is very
useful because it's it's clear you know
it's a set of rules for what is allowed
and what what is not allowed but then
are all structures created equal or you
know would would you say in certain
circumstances from your own experience
that you know you you discerned the
existence of a certain kind of structure
of good and bad and and just couldn't
accept it yourself yeah i know this is
the whole point of it if you're you know
especially
people who are autistic often in these
structures especially if it's causing
friction with a with their ways of
living and we already have these micro
routines that we need to adhere to to
feel safe and that can often kind of rub
against the institution and this is one
of the reasons why it's really good to
recognize this and not demonize yourself
because my mum always said to me if you
um you know just because you know the
system like you you don't get on with
the system it's because you're born to
make a new one and i'm a firm believer
in that even if it's a system just for
you
other people can be inspired by it right
it's it's natural which is a good it's a
good uh transition into the chapter on
friendship and biochemistry which i
thought was was very charming i mean one
of the one of the things one of the
points you make right away was the idea
that uh
you started out being sort of charmingly
immune to peer pressure because you
didn't understand it you didn't
understand when you were being pressured
by your peers so he didn't worry about
it as much and had to sort of
learn to consciously realize when your
peers were trying to pressure you
yeah this is the thing like i don't know
how to well i don't know how to
manipulate people and i don't expect
people to manipulate me and so because
that expectation
isn't there i i'm like why is he doing
that i'm just making me feel a little
bit weird but i'm probably fine and then
like hours later i'll be like oh wait a
minute that's kind of mean yeah so
um
it was it was an immune pressure because
i didn't really understand it there and
then it's really nuanced um which kind
of helpful with my protection there and
then but um
yeah um
it's something i still i'm yet to
understand but it's it's it's
if you know what affects you and can
feel that and question that then that's
pretty much how i dealt with it is
questioning it well and you also tell
the story of you know collecting data
literally sitting at the playground
looking at the different cliques form uh
and you know they're loners and popular
kids i guess and and
just as uh as a scientist
looking at what was happening and
developing theories on the basis of all
this information that was coming in yeah
exactly i didn't really feel like i was
part of any of the any of the
cliques or
groups on the playground that i saw and
so i thought well i don't want to hang
around with those because i don't i
don't i don't feel any affinity with
them but i like this bench just so
happens over the playground and this is
my spot this is my place and i feel
really happy here and um that's the
thing and i could see people and i love
the dynamics of different groups because
it was like looking at you know it's
like a fire isn't it you can get
mesmerized by its movements and the
analogy that you draw in the chapter is
with biochemistry biochemistry of course
i
make no claims to understand and it's
infinitely complicated but apparently
you had a little epiphany when watching
a football team this is what we
americans would call soccer but the
point is that uh you realize that
they're like proteins
and explain the analogy between
people on a team and proteins well
basically this is me looking at cliques
on the playground there's lots of blob
big blobs of people and small blobs of
people and they kind of all work
together but cooperatively and sometimes
not so cooperatively to
have a certain goal either be dominating
the playground or just you know um
i don't know just not getting bullied or
fitting in and i was i like to watch
football i find it very therapeutic um
and i thought wait a minute these are
doing the same it's almost like a form
of agent-based modelling that i had had
in my head when i was about 13. it's a
very good model for modeling um discrete
agents that have a common goal and
i thought wait a minute we're like
people the dynamic each football player
is like someone on the playground
someone sits together some of them don't
but they have a motive and to just to
shoot the goal and i thought this is
amazing because they're similar
especially when they orchestrate
cellular signal in the cell for example
to communicate the environment to the
cell nucleus to grow morbical nutrients
and i was like this is very much like a
clique you've got different protein
elements that have different roles but
nevertheless
kind of interlinked each other so they
can go from outside to inside to a
decision and i love that and there's
something about proteins that you
understand better than i do so uh maybe
your your professional expertise can
help us here because there's you bring
up the fact that human beings for
example will have different faces at
work and at home will sort of have
different personalities or whatever and
i gathered
that i think i know more about human
beings than about proteins so do
proteins also have this feature that
they can sort of behave in different
ways in different contexts yeah
completely especially when you look at
protein domains so there is these things
where you know evolutionary models um of
that can perform certain functions you
can have a protein that has just one
function you can have different domains
that act together that have evolved to
um from two different function but for
one hybrid function so there are many
different ways and alters kind of
activity through
the domains it possesses but also it
binding other proteins and i found that
exquisite
and and there's a there's even if i
understand what you said in the book
there's even a nature and nurture kind
of thing i mean there's the structure of
the protein just from its chemical
composition
uh morphology but then
proteins learn or are affected by their
environments in some way that we would
analogize to the nurturing of a human
being yes completely um so i looked at
the genome pushing structure from the
when it's expressed in dna and then it's
into rna oh
and then it's made into a protein and it
folds accordingly
um based on the sequence it possesses
but also its environment and also with
the help of other proteins that help it
fold in a certain shape that the
performance function and i was like oh
my god there's so much like um you know
because protein folding is a whole new
field of biochemistry itself where it's
very difficult to
predict from just one sequence what the
structure is going to be
and um if we know the structure then we
know a lot more about its behavior and
where drugs bind it's a it's a big topic
which is why an alpha fold was such a
success um even though it was based on
pretty much a decade of active research
um
so yeah um you know proteins much like
people are a consequence of their dna
but also
are inextricably linked to but then uh
like a good scientist you say that you
know the analogy is not perfect because
you say that the protein molecules do
not have egos but the human beings do so
we have to be careful not to uh think of
human beings too much like a little bit
of protein because
you can bruise the feelings of a human
being in which case
in the sense that the proteins don't
really feel
i i guess so i mean one can interpret
many ways in in
in this analogy but for me is about to
highlight the biological versatility
between how a protein can perform in
different environments and it be
beneficial to the cell for example you
know not to bring up cancer in a
positive light but it definitely uses
this mechanism of um
um
it's called protein promiscuity to try
and alter the functions to adapt to its
environment and i think it's we can
learn a lot about how biology adapts so
that we can kind of let loose of the ego
and actually express ourselves in many
so it's actually called protein
promiscuity um actually well this is
what you can have listen these proteins
called promiscuous uh proteins but
specifically enzymes which can bind many
different substrates which is very good
for like metabolism and you binding lots
of different intermediates so you can
have generalist enzymes and specialists
and um yeah that's a whole new field
itself it's really cool actually give
the protein in cancer you know there are
many yeah
and this is pretty close i mean maybe
this is a little bit of a
uh
divergence but that's okay this is
pretty close to your actual academic
work right which we haven't really
talked about you're a
cancer bioinformatics
can you tell us what that is what you do
in your day job
yes so basically i'm a scientist um
looking at the um
i guess the genomic and proteomic data
of cancer evolution so the unique thing
about it is that there are many dif
there's lots of different data there's
lots of layered multi-omics of what a
cancer is about um at any one time point
however that can change dramatically
throughout its evolution so the great
thing about um my work and what i love
about it is the fact that we have data
at different points in the tumor and at
different time points so the lab that i
um collaborated with um it's called
tracer x since the francis quick
institute they've done a remarkable job
in making the most of static
measurements to make system by actually
taking these measurements of different
spaces and and time so um and from that
we're trying to convergence
within these time points on which
mutations converge to protein structures
aka throughout protein evolution
throughout cancer evolution what are the
proteins that are most effectively
different time points and that helps us
prioritize a bit more about which are
responsible for resistance
okay cool i mean that's that's assistant
someday you'll have to write a book
about this too because i think this is a
very exciting uh rapidly moving field
and then okay the final thing on the
biochemistry uh you draw another really
good analogy about different kinds of
chemical bonds right because probably
again i'm oh maybe i'm over interpreting
so you can help me here but um you might
naively think that you know people like
each other don't like each other and
that's more or less it but the there's a
richness in different kinds of chemical
bonds of covalent ionic etc that that
that actually helps us understand some
of the richness of human attractions and
and repulsion yeah so basically it was
it was it was something that i tried to
um
i didn't realize i was modeling it to be
honest it was an accident um
in english someone asked me about the
relationship between two characters in a
book and for me it was it wasn't about
the uh kind of curse of nuance it was
more about like the mathematical
formulae because you asked me what
relationship is i'm like okay modeled
throughout time
and for me it was 10x and my everyone
laughed like big time they thought i was
making the mickey but i was like no this
is actually a solid answer you just
don't realize it yet
and
then i started to realize that these
different bonds were actually a dynamic
equilibrium between attachment and
attachment and i was like wait a minute
they're just like chemical bonds and so
i spent time just kind of looking at the
chemical bonds i learned in
a levels of gcse and also the different
people that i knew and so i spent a lot
of my time mapping what i thought i knew
into what i should have and i found that
actually there was quite a lot of you
know interactions be ionic or covalent
and some quite a lot of them hydrophobic
well no expand upon the the hydrophobic
bullies a little bit right
because people probably don't even know
a lot about what it means to be a
hydrophobic molecule well like you know
you have these cliques of people that
are scared to interact with anyone else
because it might affect their reputation
and they're only content when they're
together because they have the
commonality of not wanting to interact
with anything that's different well oil
molecules the same if you look at you
drop
oil and water they cage together because
it's more and you know it's more
thermodynamically favorable because to
interact with water if you're non-polar
it's very difficult place to be like
well i've got nothing to grab on to i'm
just gonna you know
cage with my um with someone that's
similar to me so a lot of bonds were
based on kind of looking at the
different atoms and sharing electrons
and pulling them and apart together was
this was actually quite different this
was kind of an active of polarity and i
was like yeah some people do that
because they're scared to interact with
yeah yeah i don't know if that offers
any solutions to how to deal with those
people but it is it is a vivid uh
connection
and it actually again it offers a nice
that was a really good time oh yes i
didn't even try so that's my best funds
are unintended
um
and it slides right into the last thing
i wanted to talk about which is your
chapter on etiquette and game theory i'm
a big fan of game theory i love it and
uh
etiquette is is tricky it's a it's a
hard thing especially like we said in
british cultures of all places where
there's a royal family and all the way
on down uh the to the hoi polloi
um so you you mentioned that your one's
first instinct is to treat everybody the
same and especially when you were
younger like you did not
perceive differences of age and status
or anything like that when you
interacted with different kinds of
people no and that got me into big
trouble with teachers and figures of
authority
um
and so yeah i didn't really question
etika i just knew that i had to hold my
chopsticks a certain way i had to hold
my knife and fork a certain way i
thought it was kind of a very practical
measure etiquette but over time and even
ever some more now i'm updating my
models of
etiquette because it isn't just about
um interacting with someone making them
feel comfortable it's actually being
aware of the fact that not everyone is
equal it's treating them equally but
sometimes you know you have the social
context of black lives matter and be
colour blind so for example if you treat
if you act as if that history doesn't
happen that could be quite offensive so
i think etiquette today takes on a very
different tune than um being colorblind
um for example and you need to be to
have the real etiquette is to a to not
discriminate in the first place but
there's another level now where to be
more aware of the differences that can
occur for example in transgender in
sexuality uh lgbt um plus there's lots
of different new etiquette and i think
it's about navigating those i could
write a whole book on that one i find
that quite interesting topic
no it is i mean i think you're making a
very good point here because of course
there's a lot of resistance to
uh underrepresented or discriminated
against cultures or subgroups of people
asking for
their due or you know being treated as
they want to be treated um people you
know people have a certain way of acting
and they like that way of acting and
they don't want to be told that it's
been harmful all along but but you're
making the point that that's that's that
kind of relearning of how to treat
people is just something that you had to
learn from the start for everybody
exactly yeah and i think whenever
someone says to me oh i wasn't brought
up with that oh that's a that's a
useless thing to consider i'm like well
it's not because i've managed to learn
something that i didn't realize was
useful
but actually it's made me connect more
with people and be more empathetic so
i don't excuse if you can't learn it i'm
like well if i did
right exactly and it's it's a tricky
thing because
there's sort of the explicit
rules of etiquette that we can you know
just ask somebody ask somebody and
they'll tell us
but there's a lot of
things that are implicit a lot of things
that you're either just supposed to pick
up from the ether or or infer from
behavior and so
the
the the work of making those implicit
things a little bit more explicit is
probably useful for everybody yeah which
is why
i think it's also not being afraid to
ask and i think people associate asking
with being rude but it's not for example
if i said to you what are your pronouns
it's okay it's okay to ask
because we're still learning and i think
this is where etiquette has changed that
asking is actually a polite thing right
very very i think it's a valuable lesson
to learn all around and your extra thing
that you're adding here is to analogize
it or even just use game theory uh to
think about this i mean game theory we
talked about modeling agent-based
modeling etc but game theory has this
extra complication in that need to
understand the goals of the other person
in order to find the happy equilibrium
for all of us yeah completely and i
think it's about knowing that there is
more to
an event happening than or than just
what you want and this element of
cooperation is basically um a very
innate in an evolution we
as much as we like to be individualistic
and independent and unproductive and all
these buzzwords ultimately we're doing
it because we're doing it for love
a bit of a romanticist when it comes to
this kind of thing i think everyone
ultimately wants to make sure that their
family is happy and well fed and even
though we might be territorial of our
land or this but ultimately it's it's to
a togetherness that it can't be modeled
but i think when it comes to etiquette
it's the absence of game theory it's
doing things just because because that's
kind of and and in game theory you know
there's different kinds of games
depending on what the payoff structure
is right there's prisoner dilemma games
you know i've done podcasts on game
theories and remarkable richness of
possibilities i mean do you
how explicit are you in thinking about
oh this interaction is this kind of game
or is that just sort of background
knowledge that uh is more implicit
um i like i say i go into conversations
with no agenda whatsoever and so i spent
my time trying to decipher what games
people are playing
and that can be exhausting
um
so yeah
that's where i come from like okay what
game are you playing are you playing any
game oh you're not okay that's nice it
can be friends right right well
you know it's quite a journey you know
uh
you have a phd you've written the book
uh the book has won prizes uh you've
been pretty successful at figuring this
out and but so i think it's
i hope that people do read the book
because
uh one could see your sort of current
success and not realize what it took to
get there i mean you mentioned in the
book that you felt human for the first
time when you're around 17 years old and
uh that's a difficult thing to imagine
having to go through oh thank you so
much yeah no um oh yeah no i appreciate
you saying that it did take it did take
a lot but i had nothing to compare it to
it was just a bit of a battle that
thankfully i am i surmounted in the end
yeah when i was 17 i thought okay i've
got a place here i can go from here well
and also
you know it's it's a little bit humbling
for me because uh i and friends of mine
often complain about academia and how
they're sort of very rigid standards for
what counts important contributions you
know public
engagement and writing and so forth and
podcasts do not count for example and so
we fetch about that and you know wish
things were better uh and
like you mentioned with your phd thesis
you've done this uh all while uh being
autistic and trying to learn how to how
to you know wear makeup and things like
that and so that's just an extra layer
of expectations and learning that that
we all have to fight through yeah no no
thanks i
it it's true though i think ultimately
it's just
um i'd like to think that it's living
the inevitable of what a lot of people
feel anyway but i think to the ability
to kind of say it out loud is something
that people find very useful because
they can relate to it this is what i
like and and
now that you've written the book and
it's out and things like that and you're
still doing scientific research etc i
mean what are your feelings about
balancing those different kinds of
engagement with the world do you think
that
you're more attracted to one or the
other or are you uh
devoted to the idea of doing everything
at once
um i i like i love both careers i think
um it's an honor to be able to be a
scientist and express that and mix it up
with the books that i read to create
something that i hope will be more
informative so
i love that process both of them
yeah
that's good to hear i'm very uh i'm
looking forward to what comes next
camilla pang thanks so much for being on
the mindscape podcast thank you so much
[Music]
you